ان تعرف اكثر شعار قناه العربيه عبر
السنوات ما هذا الطريقه لولاده منصه
المحتوى رقم الجديده اكثر اكثر تهدف
لتوسيع نطاق محتوى العربيه الرقمي واستهدف
المزيد من الفئه العمريه حدث اطلاق اكثر
شهد اطلاقا ثمانيه برامج رقميه جديده تركز
على مجموعه متنوعه تشمل الرعايه الصحيه
والغذاء والسفر والفن والسيارات والجديد
في عالم التقنيه و برنامج يبسط المشهد
السياسي بالاضافه لبرنامج حول العمله
الرقميه العربيه تظن ملايين المتابعين عبر
جميع حساباتها على منصات التواصل واكثر
خطوه اضافيه للحفاظ على رياده المؤسسات في
المنطقه اكثر قربا وصدقا ومهنيا واليوم
سنخذكم في رحله الى عالم بابعاد جديده
لتكون على بعد ضغطه زر واحده لتعيش معنا
ضيوفا اكثر عفويه
احداثا اكثر بساطه دراما اكثر تشويقا قصه
جديده رقميه للعربيه حدثنا اكثر الجميع
يتساءل ما هي اكثر اكثر هي منصه رقميه همم
العربيه همم تشمل البرامج عديده مستهدفين
فيها الشباب اللي قاعدين على الجوالاتهم
يبون الماده السريعه الخفيفه الظريفه
فاكثر
هدفها هو خلق محتوى عصري شبابي يستهدف هذا
الشريحه الشبابيه طيب فرح اكثر طبخت على
نار هادئه يعني كان في سريه محاطه بها هل
كان افضل ان تحاط بالسريه حتى نرى النتيجه
والعرض المبهريه وما امس من قبلكم يعني
هذا جزء من التسويق انه نشتغل عليها على
نار هادئه وكمان جزء من الانتاج تبعنا
يعني احنا بدانا تقريبا ل 2019
بانتاج البرامج الديجيتال واطلقناها كان
سوفت لانش مثل ما يقولون
فشفنا ان الوقت الان مناسب ان احنا نطلقها
بشكل تحت مظله واحده بضم جميع البرامج
انها تستهدف الشباب الذين يستخدمون
موبايلاتهم وتحدثين بالتفصيل عن البرامج
التي تشملها اكثر اكيد عندنا طبعا برامج
منوعه في كافه المجالات همم عندنا توبموشن
تبع سينما فايبر لايف ستايل في السياره
الى الموتورز والسيارات كمان عندنا شيء
تاكله التكنولوجيا سياسه همم اكسبلينغ او
شرح الاحداث التاريخيه والمصطلحات
السياسيه واشياء عديده يعني
طيب فرح يوم امس في هذا العرض في مذيعه
استفزتني شوي هي مذيعه روبوت
ما هي ميرا وشو راح تعمل وش راح يكون
دورها او شيء شكرا انك قدمتي الحفل نادين
كنت ضعيفه معانا رائعه الصراحه وانبسطنا
بوجودك كثير وحبيت تعليقك على ميرا انه لا
تاخذي مكاننا في
الاعلام هي ميرا صراحه تجربه احنا كثير
متحمسين عليها ميرا افاتار
عملناه همم يقدم برنامج خاص عن
التكنولوجيا المستقبل
فراح نشوف كيف ردود فعل الناس على وجود
افاتار يقدم البرنامج امير على فكره خفيفه
الدم كثير ظريفه
وراح تتفاعل مع الناس راح تتفاعل مع
تعليقاتهم ايضا همم راح نشوف متحمسين نشوف
النتيجه راح تنطلق اليوم ان شاء الله على
الصاج